you
you
hello everyone how's everyone today I
hope as good as me I'm doing fine and
today I'm gonna be discussing a little
bit of the Peter bill debate that we had
a couple weeks ago and specifically I'm
gonna be analyzing the slit experiment
that Peter challenged okay
and so you know specifically I'm gonna
go over the I'm gonna review the solut
experiment and then I'm gonna go over
some of the questions he put up
regarding the Rope of light and we're
gonna see how it goes I'm gonna look at
these two issues so let's go with a
review first what Peter was trying to do
the other day and where we have our
differences here's the issue the issue
is that let's see if I can get this up
there here's the analysis again of the
debate and what were the problem well
the problem with the slit experiment was
that he claimed that he handled one
electron at a time okay now he didn't do
the experiment he's just saying he's
just speaking for Tana Mora who was one
of the persons who handled electrons one
electron at a time when he did the slit
experiment and Tana Morra really did it
13 years after Murli the Italian who
headed a you know an Italian group and
they had done it first but for some
reason they always give credit to Tana
Mora I have no problem because either
way I think it's nonsense anyways and
I'm gonna
you know summarize that we discussed
that last week I'll just go over real
quickly Dannemora
says he handled one electron at a time
if so he's got a dualist rate his atom
that's what I think he's got to do I
mean if he if an electron is a wave
that's different than if an electron is
a discrete particle and we need to know
what his atom looks like before he goes
in there and you know claims that he
handled one electron at a time if if if
the electron is an orbiting bead you
know he's got it you tell me that
unambiguous he's gotta tell us for sure
you know that it's a little bead because
we need to know you know what he
admitted and what he received so if he's
gonna say that he admitted an electron
bead and he detected an electron bead at
the screen or at the detector well the
next step is he's gotta identify the
medium that you know that keeps the
electron bound to the nucleus in other
words he's got to draw the item for us
he's gotta tell us soon in this case I
put a little picture there he's got to
tell us what the green stuff is in other
words if this is his model of the atom
and it is because that's what Peter
essentially Illustrated you know then
he's got to tell me what that green
stuff is and he went through this
rigmarole saying you know that it was a
potential and a potential of what well a
potential of a voltage and that it was
sunk and I said you know that's not a
physical object and so he went on there
saying it was a fabric and fabric of
space and he just kept changing the
words that's all he did he never
identified that green stuff specifically
he couldn't tell me whether that green
stuff remains globular in that case you
know or circular if you prefer when the
electron goes away I mean what happens
to that green stuff does it vanish
is it still there you know all these
questions need to be answered before
anyone can claim to handle one electron
at a time before the slit experiment or
for whatever okay okay so that was our
starting point again if the electron is
an electron bead and then as somehow it
morphs into a wave or vice-versa if it
starts being a wave and then somehow
morphs into this grid bead we need to
see or we need to understand the
mechanism by which one converts into the
other how does a particle you know this
Greek particle morph into an extended
wave how does an extended wave collapse
as they say to a particle we need to see
this this this has to be part of the
theory okay so you can't just wish that
away and say well you know I'll just
sweep that under the rug and that's
continued no no this this has to be
clarified okay so that was our starting
point okay what was the real problem the
real problem is that we have three
versions of what electricity is on the
under table the first one is the one
that classical mechanics has had for
certain many years
I'd say at least since the 19th century
so we're talking about at least 200
years you know beginning some somewhere
around the days old
Faraday you know 20s and 3018 20s 1830s
1840s thereabouts to today and the idea
there was you know that developed in the
19th century is the electron eventually
you know was that an electron and goes
from out of the atom fact we still have
that notion today many use that and
claim that you need a conductor you know
to to have the electrons go across
quantum has invented something in the
1920s called an electron gun and what
they claim now is that an electron does
not need a conductor or you can put that
in different terms you say everything is
a conductor it's just a matter of how
much
voltage you put between that insulation
and everything eventually becomes a
conductor so there are different ways of
seeing us we have a problem with that
very serious problem with that and so
let's go with the first one here is here
is the typical you know mechanical say
the classical mechanic version and
that's the here you have a chamber okay
you have all these atoms the red ones
there we're going to put them static for
now because that's we're not so much
interested in little details the bottom
line is that electricity is the flow of
current which are those little blue
balls those electron balls which are
going from atom to atom from the cathode
to the anode okay very simple so we
assumed that we have a bunch of atoms in
there okay the electrons simply go from
one atom to the other from one side to
the other that's the classical mechanics
or 19th century version of what an
electron and what an atom might look
like really it was beginning of the 20th
century but timing here is irrelevant
okay so what is the problem the problem
is that now the quantum folk came up
with something different they said look
we've got an electron gun and we're just
gonna shoot electrons across the divide
cross that chasm and we don't need a
conductor we can send a through empty
space and that's what they think they're
doing and that's essentially what Tana
Morra thought he did and that's what
Peter thought that Tana Maura did
because that's what Tana Morra claimed
that he did okay so that's that's how
that goes and so essentially Peter
accepted it at face value said you know
how can they be wrong they detected one
electron at a time apparently they've
been shooting one electron at a time and
here you have the model or the
illustration a little
jiff their video showing how the
electrons go from the hot cathode now
you heat up the tip and you you shoot
these marbles across empty space fine
what's the problem with this the problem
with this is that if we pump the chamber
down remember this is a chamber we have
gas coming in from one end and we have
the other end or an outlet connected to
a couple of pumps they could be you know
a mechanical pump in series with either
a cry or a diffusion pump so we're going
to pump the chamber now say 2-7 range
which is a typical range that I work at
least with I'm familiar with that range
and we're gonna pump the chamber down
and what happens if we pump the chamber
down we have removed all the obstacles
that the electron is going to bounce
against and by doing so we should get a
higher current we should get something
that looks like this okay
that's what we should get why we removed
all the atoms events which many
electrons are bouncing and the mean free
path has increased so now we should get
more electrons in other words the
electricity the current should go up
this is not the case any person who who
has any knowledge of anything who's
worked with vacuum pumps and with vacuum
chambers and with electricity will tell
you that this is not the case our
experience shows that this is not the
case and if we are to use mr. Karl
Popper not that you should but if we are
to use them this falsifies the electron
gun notion that quantum mechanics has
introduced okay it falsifies it in the
sense that we're saying this is not the
case if if you remove material from the
chamber with the same temperature and
with the same voltage you will get a
lower current in fact you may not get
any current at all you do need to
increase the voltage and the reason
that is again that you need some
conductor in there by removing all
conductors for example if you could
possibly write evacuate to chamber
completely so that there is no atoms in
there whatsoever you will not get a
current period okay so those people who
think that they're shooting electrons
across empty space like the electric
universe these people think that
electrons just fly through the plasma
you know the enormous amount of plasma
that fills space between galaxies you
know they think they're shooting
electrons across this enormous chasm
this divide and and that it's these
electrons that hold galaxies together
because they don't believe in gravity
okay so they think it's all done with
electricity and the part of folk don't
propose that for the universe out there
but they do propose it for their
chambers they propose the same mechanism
they're saying if we remove the atoms
from the chamber we should get higher
current because you know the mean free
path has increased that is typically for
sure not the case you can take that to
the bank
okay okay so that's that's my criticism
of with Peter propose and what Connemara
by extension proposed so you can get rid
of all that nonsense right now okay
there is no such thing as an electron
gun shooting bullets and so what do I
propose what's the third option we have
atom electrons going from atom to atom
we have electron just flying through
empty space okay and then we have Bill's
rope versioned rope hypothesis version
and that's a series of atoms here I just
put a single atom just for the sake of
showing the mechanism okay obviously
this is a little more complicated and
we're really talking about molecules etc
etc here I just put a whole bunch of
atoms there
bow to each other of their merged we
have merged electron shells because
that's what it is the atom is under the
rope model and these merged electron
charges twirl in place so what you have
is essentially a torsion going from
cathode to anode okay and all we have is
really clockwise and counterclockwise
that's all mother nature understands she
doesn't understand negative and positive
she understands counterclockwise and
clockwise that she does understand and
because that's physics and so here you
have the diversion from the rope model
okay so you have those three models one
more time let's go through them real
quick here's the classical model okay
little beads going from atom to atom you
have the quantum mechanics which is
little bees going through empty space no
atoms no conductor necessary and you
have the Rope version which is you know
what I say a serpentine twirling in
place what you have is all these atoms
just bound together and twirling in
place actually molecules okay okay so
that's where we stand today those are
three models it's up to you the theta to
you know figure out which one you like
the best
okay that's what we got to do here okay
so what's the issue with ton of Moreh
that was one issue the other one is that
Tana Mora does a little sleight of hand
which is very common to do in quantum
mechanics and he goes something like
this you know what kind of work did he
says he he emitted electron waves he
said coherent electron waves from my
sharp field emission tip that's a gun
okay
they called it an electron gun field
emission that's what they do were set to
an electron by prison okay so that's
what he sent what did he observe well he
observed single electrons in other words
he's surf at the at the detector he
detected or you know there you see the
picture he detected these inner
ference fringes on the wall you put a
detector there and essentially he said
he could collect single electrons one at
a time on the screen and he says you
know how what else could it be so he
says you know it had to be one electron
out of time because we were able to
build the the interference pattern one
electron at a time sound sounds like a
open-and-shut case right nothing to
argue well the first problem is again he
sent electron waves and he collects
single electrons that's the first
problem okay let's go with a second
problem here here's the set up okay
and he says electrons are emitted one by
one from the source this is a lie this
is what he tells the reporters okay this
was not in his paper this is what he
tells his reporters he says he sent them
one electron at a time when in his
report he says something totally
different he says no what he said is he
sent electron waves to an electron by
prism he sent waves and now he's talking
about what particles one at a time and
he's detected one by one as particles at
the detector that's how he says he
detected them okay so again anyone who
makes these claims has to do a single
thing you know and that's draw the atom
to steal the stricture atom if it's a
little bead going around because you're
gonna be handling one electron at a time
right so you can't start with a wave if
you say I mean you gotta choose did you
pull a wave out of your gun or did you
pull an electron bead which which of the
two did you pull out of your gun
well he's to the public he says he
pulled a bead and in the paper he wrote
that he pulled a wave so we got a
problem there okay so please draw your
atom what does your atom look does it
look like you know does the electron
look like a wave that surrounds the atom
is it a cloud that's around
you know the wave you would think is is
like the Broglie wave it's uh it's just
a hula hoop a little undulated hula hoop
right that's that's what do you what do
you think of when he talks about a wave
if if the electron is around you know
the nucleus
it's a hula hoop and and if it's
spherical well which is the cloud model
borns cloud model okay so now we have
two different kinds of electrons any of
if the electors really a bead and the
cloud is really the the orbital the
region where you can find the bead now
we have a third version of the atom we
have three versions of of the quantum
atom it's a little bead that goes around
that's the electron the other one is the
orbital which is like a shell which is
like a cloud that envelopes the nucleus
and with which they do you know covalent
bonding and other stuff so you know
they're using the orbital as a physical
entity and then there's the Broglie hula
hoop which is just the you know integral
waves around you know the nucleus we
have three verses Tana Maura's got to
tell us which one he's gonna use and he
can't tell the public oh we we used the
bead and then you know he tells the
people in the industry you know the
specialized journals he tells those
folks he said well we really admitted
waves okay so keep that in mind that's
important okay so what what is the issue
the issue is that you know time Tamura
believes he's dealing with cannonballs
that's how quantum does it stuff it
shoots cannonballs makes holes with
cannonballs right that's how Kimura says
that he made the holes on the wall or
how he detected one ball at a time at
the detector or at the screen he built
his interference fringes one ball at a
time one shot at a time and then we have
you know Bill Gates different
in which is the drill bit twirly in
place this is another way to make holes
and a little more modern way by the way
then you know shooting cannonballs
I guess Tana Morris still you know he's
still in the old age and you know
fighting with tannins over whatever so
he's got that maybe in his mind I don't
know all of quantum is still in the 19th
century in that sense
okay so we have drill bit twirling in
place one more time here he goes that's
the model that I propose and you say
well how do you relate that to the Rope
model okay so here it is here is
electricity and magnetism but in both of
in one single image okay we're saying
that a electricity consists of a row of
atoms really molecules we're just going
to deal with atoms for now and they're
twirling in place they form a serpentine
they're all blended with each other so
they form this row and are twirling in
place okay and because they're twirling
in place they swing threads around it
the rope that unites all these atoms one
of the two threads are released and they
swing around the twirling atoms and
those gazillions of threads that are
twirling around the earth can be the
magnetic field and as you can see the
threads are spinning or or swinging at
90 degrees to the flow of electric
current so we're consistent with
experience and with observation and the
Orthodox version is the one on below and
that's you know the flow of beads so we
have two different mechanism according
to Tana Morra in quantum mechanics
turned consists of a flow of beads okay
and along the wire and in the case of
the Rope model we have a twirly
serpentine that's what I call those
merged electron shells
and that swing threads around themselves
and those threads will form the magnetic
field okay so that's the model that I'm
proposing and we can see with that why
we have voltage we know that current
again from experience a current flows
spirally around a wire and what quantum
does is say well we have positive but
one end negative the other end we caught
voltage we don't know what voltage is
it's a potential whatever potential is
it's a difference in potential or
whatever that means and here we say look
you know what it is is you have the
entire serpentines
there either clockwise at one end and
they had better be counterclockwise at
the other end no matter what wire you
use in the in the universe if you curl
the wire at one end clockwise from the
other end you will see it
counterclockwise and and that's the
issue that's what voltage is voltage is
not a potential where you have more
water here and less water there and an
inclined plane where water runs down to
hill that's not voltage voltage is
clockwise and counter clockwise there
are two ends of a wire that's what it is
that's what Mother Nature understands
and again until they define what voltage
is we don't have that you know and not
define it I mean Illustrated we don't
have a notion of what these people are
talking about in terms of the
electricity what do you mean voltage
what is voltage you say well it's a
difference in potential yeah what does
that mean just mathematics same five
volts here negative volts 5 volts over
there what does that mean in physical
terms again they have to illustrate it
we don't want any math we don't want any
numbers what we want is a picture a
photograph a movie okay that's what we
want we want to see something with our
eyes that's not an equation or a number
okay so what does that take us there
takes us to the slit experiment here's
my version of the slit experiment based
on that in a musing Tana Morris picture
there what it is essentially is that the
what is it the serpentines are twirling
in place and the plates there see you
see the the slit here is formed between
one plate and the other plate with the
filament in between okay so the slits
are in this sense right is where the
green serpentines are moving around okay
that's gonna be the slits in terms of
electrons okay in terms of electricity
and what we're saying is all we're doing
there is just spinning electrons or
spinning electron shells right that are
merged and and they we focus them on a
screen or on a detector and that's where
we get the interference because they
either are in sync or they're out of
sync they're in phase or they're out of
phase that's all it is okay so the model
is very simple to understand once you
have a picture of it okay okay so what
are our conclusions well here are the
conclusions I'm saying electron gun
misleads mathematicians to believe that
electron beads fly through the vacuum
that is not at all the case as an ideal
vacuum an ideal vacuum is a perfect
insulator electricity requires a
conductor if electricity consists of a
flow electron beads the proponent must
illustrate the atom if the theorist
illustrates the electron as an orbiting
bead he needs to illustrate the medium
that prevents the bead from flying
spontaneously
out of the atom either potential no
voltage as Peter suggested you know
qualifies as a fabric or as a physical
medium the word fabric is really very
misleading and neither of altijd nor
potential or fabrics and fabric is not a
physical object either by the way you
can say you know what is it a fabric of
cloth cloth you can say that fabric is
what a cloth is made out of it's all
these you know threads or strings or
whatever that you sew together that's a
fabric so to say that you know voltage
is a fabric
potential as a fabric is meaningless
totally meaningless or space-time is a
fabric same thing voltage is defined as
a difference in potential and
mathematical physics has no physical
interpretation for voltage therefore it
is irrational to state that a concept
such as voltage binds the electron bead
to the nucleus of the atom and
physically prevents its departure period
claims that lab technicians have handled
one electron our assumptions which
they've turned into proofs and claims
that the slit experiment was performed
by sending one electron at a time cannot
be recorded as scientific until the
theorists illustrate their version of
the atom and a quantum physical
interpretation of the slit experiment is
unscientific because the electron is
regarded to be a wave at emission and a
particle at impact
quantum does not explain the mechanism
of this magical conversion and that's
what they have to do you know if they're
going to say that they handle one
electron at a time well draw your atom
and show us what keeps it bound to the
nucleus to begin with
the electron keeps the electron bound to
the nucleus to begin with we need to see
that okay then they can move on from
there otherwise they don't even have a
theory they don't have a you know a case
okay but we didn't stop our discussion
there we had a discussion about the rope
model and a problem there was that
unfortunately Peter did not do much of a
research on the rope model and that took
away from the discussion because you
know there was not much to discuss when
he didn't understand some of the basics
some of the fundamentals of the Rope
model more more fundamental yeah and I
wanted to get into you know the
foundations of physics what is what is
physics about that we need an object and
he kind of brushed that I said well he
did address that but I mean he didn't do
a good job of that on the one hand he
said you need an object then he starts
talking about you know fabric of
potentials or a fabric of space-time or
a fabric of you know voltage and again
that means he didn't understand what we
mean when we say that you need an object
in physics that's not a none of those
qualifies as an object
for the purposes of physics and did this
the dialogue went something like this
okay here it is so that we're all on the
same page that's a little too big and
let's see if we can shorten a little bit
okay so something like this Peter you
have your magnetic rope and you have
your electric rope I have no idea where
he got that or what he's talking about
is this accurate no it's not that you
have two ropes and that's when they
unwind and they come back together again
I don't know where he got this I don't
he obviously did not do a minimum of
research on the rope you would think
that you know all he did was send me
four papers and said those four papers
challenged the rope model because I
cannot explain those experiments with a
rope but he never figured out what the
Rope model was about or are they two
separate ropes does rope conform with
known physics and I like that question
because and that's the one I want to
address specifically does the Rope
conform with known physics so let's look
at that does the rope conform with known
physics and I'm saying yeah the rope
model can explain many features
especially of light and it can explain
straightness why light travel straight
or rectilinear Li right it can explain
undulate wide light is undulatory why
it's wavy I can explain why light is so
fast and it can explain also why light
always meets a target its target it
always finds its target no matter where
I mean you can move the moon anywhere
you want and and it'll stay within
vision of your eye and you see how can
that be if the moon is is movie you know
and maybe the moon doesn't move very
fastest one kilometer per second around
the Earth but you can take some you know
like Halley's Comet probably moves
faster I have no idea how fast Halley's
Comet moves but I
who's faster and and you can see it and
it's not always at the same place you've
seen instantaneously like when you're
flying a kite you know you you scanned a
kite or around the the the sky and you
always see it miracle well yeah because
you you have the string tied to the kite
wherever the kite goes that's your line
of sight and that's the that's what
we're saying happens with the Rope model
you're essentially flying a kite you get
a direct connection at all times
whatever moves out there and so let's go
step by step here's the issue of speed
okay
here's why the rope explains you know
the speed of light white so fast okay
and here we have Lisa's compared to the
transverse wave transverse wave and
longitudinal waves you know they're
they're very slow compared to a torsion
wave and you can show this to yourself
you know just take any rope your
grandmother's rope tight tightly between
two walls and just put two clothes pins
at the far ends and just push one one
clothespin yellow one will move
instantaneously that's how fast a
torsion wave is the tighter you have
that rope the faster that torsion wave
if you we can call it that
you know moves from one end to the other
of that rope in comparison you know
one-way waves such as longitudinal waves
and transverse waves they're very slow
and it turns out that a longitudinal
wave is even faster than a transverse
wave as you can see there the turtle
beats that beats the poor little snail
and you say well is that really true I
mean does a is a longitudinal wave
faster than a transverse wave yeah and
here it is here we have a case also take
to the bank
okay cash it in during earthquakes
they've measured longitudinal PE seismic
waves are known as primary seismic wave
to call P waves and they reach e 1.7
times faster than transfers S wave shear
waves
okay the shear wave takes longer to get
to your house than the longitudinal
seismic wave okay and so you know just
as a comparison sound is a longitudinal
wave so if this is the case if light
consists of transverse waves then when
there is a thunder lightning you should
hear the Thunder faster than you could
see the light and that is obviously not
the case because you know thunder would
be a longitude sound right the boom that
you hear that's a longitudinal wave and
the light the flash that you see that's
supposed to be a transverse wave well
you know if we were to follow the
analogy of the earthquake you should see
the thunder before you you should hear
the thunder the thunder before you see
the flash and obviously that's not the
case so it's questionable very
questionable if you know light is a
transverse wave because a transverse
wave is about the slowest thing we've
got out there as far as waves are
concerned okay and again and here if you
go with the torsion wave see if I can
find it here again you go with a torsion
wave there it is no give me a second
here
the torsion wave is much faster than
either a longitudinal wave in a or a
transverse wave but it also has another
feature that it goes that is that it
goes both ways
transfers ways and longitudinal waves
are one-way waves they only go in one
direction outwards whereas the torsion
yo or you know if it's along an existing
elongated Meccan pagent such as a rope
or a chain or cable it goes both in both
directions and the good thing about it
you can explain entanglement with that
because at one end you're gonna have
clockwise and then the other hand you
had better have counterclockwise so you
know entanglement which is a big monster
for the people in quantum mechanics is a
no brainer in under the Rope model
whatever is clockwise at one end that
better be counter clockwise at the other
end okay so that tells you a little bit
about speed now let's see if we can look
at straightness here's the other feature
that the rope model can answer here you
have a transverse wave which is what
quantum says or mathematical physics in
general says light consists of and you
can see the torsion there the torsional
wave you know not only is it very
straight right there the rope is at
least straight and that means that
torsion can only travel until the
undulating but you know along a straight
line and the transverse wave you can't
do that no matter how you do it
the transverse waves not going to be
very very straight and not very fast
either you can see the torsion wave is
much faster conceptually and the other
good thing about it is that you know the
torsion wave is always stuck to a target
the targeting go anywhere it wants and
you can't do that with the transverse
wave if it's one a one-way mechanism one
way agent
you know by the time you send the next
wave the targets no longer there
so the torsion also has that an
advantage where you know it's already
connected at the other end the rope is
and you're just sending torsions along
that rope so it's a much more efficient
much more rational system than the
standing wave of quantum mechanics and
here's a here's another version of that
another vision let's see I think it's
this one
these two guys are doing a transverse
wave okay that they're using what's
known as a standing wave note that first
the guy has to hold on the guy in the
right over there the young guy he's got
to hold on to to the rope if he lets go
of that rope that's gonna sag all the
way to the floor you won't get a
transverse wave that's the first problem
okay but let's keep it there what
happens the you can see that the Rope is
not very straight it's sagging it's
going all over the place absolutely
not very straight at all I'm wondering
if light behaves like that when it goes
to the mirror from your face to the
mirror does light really want that much
um maybe if you had too many beers it
would but certainly not you know by its
very nature like those straight period
and we have to explain that straightness
and you can either talk about
rectilinear travel or straightness
either one yeah if you're gonna talk
about particles going from one end to
the other you're gonna say well they
traveled rectilinear Li why would a
series of particles do so and in the
transverse wave has the same problem if
it's a one-way mechanism holding it at
one end is already Chi but even if we
grab that you can see that the rope that
rope or that wave is not very straight
at all is it fast
well we already discussed fast not fast
at all and then on top of that they say
well you know a transverse wave light
right needs no medium it's the waving of
nothing that it they they say it in two
ways they and the one way and or one
hand they say it's the waving of nothing
and on the other they say light does not
need a medium through which to travel so
it's a different way of saying something
similar but it's not exactly the same
okay but essentially is they're they're
trying to get a avoid of medium because
they don't know what a wave is and a
wave is not a noun it's a verb wave is
is what something does and that
something has to be identified and what
they've done is say well we can't
identify it and since it can travel
through space which supposedly has
nothing they say well then it's the
vibration of nothing they got rid of the
ether and then on the other hand they'll
say that space is made of particles
positive two particles and lt and
negative particles when these particles
come together they become no particles
and then space can also break up into
these particles so you figure it out
what these people are talking about okay
and we also have the issue of a wave
extending versus you know whether the
wave travels because see one of the
issues that I have is that these people
sometimes criticize the rope model on
that basis they say are you telling me
that the rope the electromagnetic rope
extends from an atom in the Andromeda
galaxy all the way to us to plus million
light years away it's extending all that
distance and and then a question the
answer to that question is another
question what do you to tie me as far as
your wave is concerned is your wave
extending all the way from Andromeda to
us also and if not does it travel like a
little sailboat where does the wave
begin where does the wave end I mean you
know they talk about wave
Hackett's what does that mean that means
it shoots one wave that the atom does
shoots one wave then it waits then
shoots another way and then it waits
then shoots another wave is that how it
is and all these little waves travel
like sailboats in a straight line to
your eye from Andromeda so we got the
same problem no matter whether you use
particles why did the particle travel
all that length of that distance think
about that and here's the comparison
illustrated the electrified atom and so
use a little wave being sent out and the
question doesn't extend from Andromeda
to us or does it travel like a little
sailboat the screen will sell wave
packet there's your wave packets of
being son okay so there's so much other
two is correct yeah does it extend or
does it travel and they have to address
that question before they can attack the
role model and again if the atom
produces away the question is does it
produce it the little discrete wave that
travels or all these waves connected I
mean you know whatever you see the wave
a model they show many legs together why
why don't they show wanna make it a time
why do these show a bunch of links
connected like the for the case up there
on the upper left that's what they show
they show a bunch of links that are
connected a a bunch of ways are
continuously connected and here you can
see something different they they they
in the next one here here they show you
that you know the little thing travels
that's all this sweet little bug a
little corkscrew there and so the
question is which of these two is
correct and it have the same question as
the model they can't avoid that question
either and of course they've never
questioned that they never ask the
question to begin with okay aside from
we have another problem as a as a dental
another I could get there and that's
that you know they cannot explain pull
with the particles or waves
I mean if here we have Kassim here my
little friend there and he's throwing
rocks at the thunk you pulling it that
way is that rational is that how autumn
does it by throwing stones is that how
to how court pulls on another blue ones
at it and it's more irrational to think
that you know you know you pull on a
donkey by pulling on a rope or some kind
of extended object that goes from here
or there but to say that you're gonna
use this green stones like you know in
the case of electrons that are being
pulled out of an electron gun and shot
against the screen or against the
detector well you know then you have
that situation there you know the
question is can you pull but that same
mechanism see we can do it we can do
both we can not only torque the robot
send you like we can also pull on the
rope and give you gravity these people
cannot send that they can I justify the
particle being the electron being a
particle first of all and then they
cannot with that same ball produce
attraction so they can't do either
yeah with the Rope you do both okay so
that's in general my criticism of what
we discussed the other day and all I can
say is that you know it's you've got the
presentation it's up to you to figure
out which way you're gonna go if you
think quantum is rational and you need
to get the particle forward waves
I mean I don't care use the wave but you
can't in the middle the rice change
horses and say oh I've converted the
wave into a particle we can
I cannot explain what a wave the impact
the single impact and then you say wool
but here spraying the fringes over that
who bring the way back again and we have
two waves just meeting parfaits on the
screen well did you have two waves
meaning you know one perpendicular to
the other but yeah but when they hit the
screen in turn into a particle and again
that conversion is what's uh fishy you
know and again you should use Karl
Popper at that point and say well you
know Karl Popper falsifies both of them
until you can figure out how do you
explain that you can't use the particle
when it's convenient for your theory and
and converted to wave at your
convenience also when it's you know when
it's handy and so this is the the
problem with quantum mechanics they
don't have a rational explanation they
don't have a physical interpretation for
the slit experiment and it is how we do
you know we do because we just convert
the party one throw away whatever it's
gonna be eating for us we shoot
particles or when you don't care doesn't
matter to us we should have wave that
collect the particle or shoot a party
bowling and then have waves interfere
they can do it either way because
they're going back and forth and you
have in the case of light you just have
two rows in in the case of electricity
if you're gonna do it with electrons
well you have merged shells and they're
spinning in place and so either way you
can explain it rationally and physically
and so that's where we stand and so
that's my criticism of Peters version
okay so we'll see you on Wednesday and
now probably uh just finishing up on
that discussion get into some other
subject like that we'll see you on
Wednesday
we'll see that